marijuana is now legal or for either
recreational or medical use in 33 states
but now there's a new warning about car
crashes involving use of the drug a
triple-a study looked at ten years of
traffic deaths in Washington state it
found the number of drivers involved in
fatal crashes who were high on marijuana
has more than doubled since pot was
legalized there in 2012 as Kris Van
Cleave reports the organization says
states must do more to stop stoned
drivers good morning marijuana
dispensaries like this one are all over
Los Angeles and triple-a is increasingly
worried about what happens when people
get stoned and then get behind the wheel
16 year old Chad Britton was walking to
his car during lunch when he was hit and
killed in front of his high school by a
teen driver high on pot he was a
beautiful soul they'd do anything for
anyone triple A's Jake Nelson worries
the rate of driving stoned is reaching a
new high as legalized cannabis becomes
more widely available if you're gonna
use marijuana you shouldn't drive and if
you know you have to drive you should
not use marijuana and any shape or form
why are you driving I'm smoking you know
that's not a good idea right - camera
video shows the kinds of run-ins with
potentially high drivers Washington
State Police say are happening more
often very common we've run into it
every day
State Patrol Lieutenant Bruce Meyer says
drivers often mix pot with booze or with
other drugs it affects your cognitive
abilities your decision-making slows
down your reaction times research from
2018 shows crashes overall we're up 6%
in Washington Nevada and Oregon compared
to neighboring states where marijuana is
banned recreational pot is now legal in
11 states and it's allowed for medical
use in 22 in a recent survey of more
than 11,000 Colorado drivers 69% of
people who identified as cannabis users
said they had driven high in the last
year and 10% believed they drove better
while stoned leading to PSAs like these
the police can't tell that I'm driving
high triple-a says states need a
two-tier system to determine who is too
high to drive testing for both recent
use and evidence of impairment laws that
limit
how much THC can be in a person's blood
as a driver are completely meaningless
in terms of allowing us to predict how
impaired somebody is behind the wheel
Triple A opposes the legalization of
recreational marijuana saying it
presents a danger to auto safety normal
a group that lobbies for the expanded
legalization of marijuana takes issue
with triple A's finding saying the
increase in stops is due to an increase
in people testing for the presence of
marijuana and that marijuana can be
detectable in the body even days after
it's ingested for CBS this morning
Saturday Kris Van Cleave Los Angeles who
are the 10% of people who think they
drive better while high that's a laugh
but